it's a pleasure to uh to introduce the
chair of our first panel this morning
like visual and literary representation
and that is Gail zone Paul draggy sao
paulo's imagine who wears many hats here
he currently works at correcting I have
the exact parameters ypres but it's
working in the office in the dean's
office at the school of hard screen
environmental studies working on special
projects currently he works on and
teaches about GIS mapping along with
many other things but he also has a very
special connection to the defendant
maleic collections here at yale
especially in the by nikki back in the
90s he spent many many years long long
time going through systematically all of
tibetan texts the manuscripts the block
prints as well as much of the artwork in
the objects cataloging them and
analyzing them it's still he wrote back
in in the mid-90s our best sort of
analytical survey of a Tibetan malayan
materials in divine ackley and I have a
special affinity for the worst of all is
done because he wrote another early
dissertation on Miller right left and we
just can't have too much Miller right
back okay I'll turn over the floor to
floor thank you Andy I'm really reminded
of my academic background I did my PhD
at Indiana under initially Tipton Norbu
[ __ ] rim / J and then helmet Hoffman
but in Indiana they never changed the
time when it comes to daylight savings
time there's an actual law to that
effect and they consider the regular
time to be God's Time and daylight
savings time to be national time which
they blamed on every president from
jefferson to franklin roosevelt and
consider that only slightly more
intrusive regulation than federal income
tax so
I'm particularly remind of that today
when i woke up at about five-thirty to
drive you out here but i'm encouraged
everyone is here and showed up on time
your we're so happy to welcome you here
to Yale and I'm happy that you had a
chance to see some things at the by
negates a remarkable collection with a
tremendously bizarre past as most event
collections tend to be and the topic
today I think is utterly fascinating I
don't really have a lot to say I'm
really more ornamental than functional
and I'm hoping just to moderate what's
going to be said but it's a really
critical issue which is how we view
ourselves as Tibbett ologist and
students of the Himalaya and and also
how we understand what people are
expressing about their own values and
themselves through what we call their
art literature and artifacts and to me
nothing could be more fascinating than
this partly because as you all know
there is so much fiction so much going
into the way we study about the
Himalayan region part of this is the
engine that drove us to do that many of
us probably had our initial contact with
the Himalayan region through very
popular forms but the more deeply we
understand it the more we understand the
complexity of it and all I can say is
that the most compelling part of it when
you boil it all down it's the remarkable
authenticity and originality of it and I
think that's what we perhaps i'll share
an appreciation of my colleagues here
today are Michael hot from school board
Antolin African Studies Rob limb is
would you like to yep from Northwestern
savoring cha kia and our respondent is
here great mimi young cook so on from
yale and we occasionally pass in the art
gallery but haven't got a chance to talk
Michael are you prepared to show again
thank you very much so good morning and
I'm sorry to be speaking in national
time and not in God's time that long try
and make the best of it and again I'd
like to add my thanks to two to Sarah
and Andrew and mark and Jacob and
everybody for for making making this
happen it's been it's been a real
pleasure I've try to adjust these these
questions in my own my own particular
way and i'm going to do kind of three
things one is briefly just to talk about
the way in which when i'm teaching has
kind of evolved and to talk about the
way in which one approaches represents
certain certain issues in the himalaya a
brief mention of what the late martin
haughton many years ago proposed to work
on which he called that the shangri-la
syndrome which I think has taken on a
new dimension obviously enjoying it more
recently and then and then in a little
more detail we'll talk about some some
literature some Nepali literature I've
been working on and try and make some
conclusions about being on the same page
and I'll explain what I mean by that
when I get to it so I was sinking back
and over the last in a day or two about
by the way in which our scholarly
engagement with the Himalaya has has
evolved in response to both perhaps our
understandings and also kind of ground
realities and thinking back to the early
years of my own career as a lecturer at
so us which I i joined so ass as a
postdoc fellow having been a student
there I joined in 1987 so just in the
last years of the panchayat regime and
I'd started teaching a course which I
called foundations of Nepali culture
which is a
the Graduate sort of general
introduction to nepali cultural history
which would include a few few lectures
on cultural and political history some
stuff on Hinduism and Buddhism in the
Nepali context some subtle amna wad and
share / cultural identity near wide arc
architecture language families the
Gurkha tradition the position of women
particularly inbound shaped three
communities were joining on Lynn
Bennett's work tourism literature etc
etc and these were looking back now I
can see really quite essential izing
narratives of what were then proposed as
kind of fairly static identities and
cultures and also based on the
assumption of the existence of something
that one could call nepali culture since
I've returned to teaching after a long
period of gaining academic management
I've been teaching and bust a master's
course a graduate course which I call
culture and conflict in their Amalia and
this is much more focused on the
post-1990 period with all the other
stuff as kind of context setting
material so there's much more here on on
the politicization and problematized
problematization of ethnic and cultural
identities and is also less confined by
the boundaries of the Nepali
nation-state with lectures on Bhutan
sick in the gorkhaland movement and so
on and I was interested last year when i
asked her students at the end of the
year whether it would have been useful
to have had something on Kashmir in this
course and I think one of the things
that crossed my mind yesterday was the
way in which we haven't even mentioned I
think Kashmir even though we've been
talking about the Himalayas because the
title and culture and conflict you know
suggested to a few prospective students
that we'd be looking at at Kashmir
because from an Indian perspective you
know if you talk about culture and
conflict in the him earlier they may
think of Kashmir before they think of
anything else but actually the student
said no we thought the Kashmir would
have introduced a whole other set of
histories and arguments and issues and
uncomplicated the course to perhaps
unnecessarily whereas what we had done
had been sort of within some kind of
cultural continuum with a sort of Nepali
vein running running through it so I
just think this presented presenting as
a sort of big beginning of my own career
and the later stages and just sort of
saying in terms of representations in
terms of teaching about beta Malia's
there's a change here and it's it's
perhaps to do perhaps with my own
understandings perhaps to do with
changing ground realities in India
mallya itself the second second point I
wanted to mention again is the sort of
shangri-la syndrome as I've called it
and I think I I was interested in this
and I think perhaps for many of us our
engagement with the Himalaya begins with
some kind of love or some kind of
romance because choosing to become a
Himalayan specialist is not a
particularly wise career move in terms
of looking for appointments and jobs in
the academic market and therefore i
think there's bears in many of our
engagements anyway back maybe i'm only
speaking for myself but i think there's
a love and as a romance about about this
part of the world it's just beautiful
it's it has her heroic locations and
it's and it's welcoming and the pleasure
a pleasure a place that it's a pleasure
to be in so I thought about this many
years ago and talked and looked actually
at Hilton's novel and wrote a piece
called looking for shangri-la from
hilton to Lama shani which came out in
1996 in which I talked talked about the
way Hilton had represented shangri-la
and the way in which the the kind of
shangri-la trope had been recycled in
writings on particular places and the
way in which it has kind of moved around
if you go back to the National
Geographic in the 1930s and 40s you will
see this invoked regularly in in
articles about the Kathmandu Valley
believe it or not whereas now it and
then it moves around it did Oh classa
candler's unveiling of last sir book is
you know the kinds of the kinds of
metaphors that are used are very very
redolent of the kind of shy
reloj syndrome and I think it still
still hangs over us a little perhaps
mostly in scholarship on the Tibetan
speaking world and perhaps particularly
with regard to Bhutan where there is
still a kind of self-censorship in that
scholarship but it's quite similar to
the kinds of things that we were talking
about in coverage of Nepal during the
panchayat period so that's those are
kind of two small points really and I
think one thing that struck me also is
what we don't include in our
representations and considerations of
the Himalaya we have not had a single
mention of Islam in the last three days
there are substantial Muslim communities
in the Himalaya and not just in Kashmir
so perhaps you know are picturing are
imagining our representation of the
Himalaya still has these these kind of
emphasis on certain aspects of of this
part of the world's cultural heritage
and and some exclusion going on here as
well in our in our imagining of of this
part of the world that's the first two
points the third one I'll just a little
bit longer to talk about which is my
kind of home territory of modern-day
parley literature and I've been working
for the last two or three years on a
more recent literature sort of stuff
that's come out since 2009 2010 and
noticed quite a radical change in in the
literary environment particularly in in
Katmandu since my earlier work in the
1990s and it's I would date this change
back to around 2005 and the publication
of this particular novel papas a cafe
which is a set in the conflict period
written by their I'm widely who was then
the editor of County port of the leading
Nepali language to our daily newspaper
and was heavily marketed to the extent
that within two years of its publication
it sold something like twenty eight
thousand copies and also had appeared in
a quite high quality English translation
and it was marketed very interestingly
and intelligently you probably can't
read the small text there but this was
an advert for palpus a cafe that
appeared regularly in a number of
different nepali language magazines the
kind of glossy news magazines such as
Nepal and so on which are Nepali
language but the advertising for purpose
a cafe was almost entirely in English
even though the novel itself was in
Nepali so there was this kind of message
that maybe you thought Nepali literature
was this kind of rusty dusty thing that
only only bomb in men and no artists and
so on wrote in red and talked about but
actually if you're if you're a racy
glossy Nepali language magazine buying
kind of person perhaps you should think
about reading this kind of stuff too and
here's an advert that acknowledges that
you can also read English so it it
brings the poly literature into the
market in a way that it hadn't hadn't
been there before and it's been followed
by I mean at these are my selections and
I've i've talked about five particular
novels in a in a longer paper that i'd
be presenting in Katmandu in july and in
no particular order these are books that
have made quite an impact at least in
the kaplan do kind of public sphere
canali blues by woody saga except i
published about three years ago again
widely discussed widely reviewed and
widely widely read by by people in
Katmandu it's a kind of fictionalized
autobiography of growing up in the
Canalis zone during the conflict period
but based on a great deal of local
detail with taru culture having quite a
place in it all gangl gora is a noble
novel by again from the same kind of
period by you kapatic which is a kind of
magical realist telling of a young
tamang women's involvement in an
insurgency suspiciously similar to the
maoist insurgency in their part in a
place that's very very obvious
and designed to represent Nepal with
this motif of the Oregon the for the
king of the tongues who was killed by
the cuss back in in the mist the mists
of ancient time appearing to her in
visions and images through through the
story again very widely read very widely
discussed novel naranja cars played
kalpa the time of the Dead which is a
novel about the return of a young
brahmin man from his education in in
Banaras at the beginning of the 20th
century in in a what is clear just
described very clear to identify very
clearly as the northeast corner of the
Kathmandu Valley with chandra shamsher
ana presiding over nepal from from
france ingavar and the way in which he
tries to introduce social reforms by
taking in a Dalit boy and making him
into a Brahmin bye bye Mary marrying a
widow so breaking a lot of the social
conventions under way in which
eventually he is he and his family are
dispossessed and expelled from Nepal so
again it's a it's a story of of
oppression revolt and banishment set in
a historical past and then move the
final example is Krishna calabasas novel
raha which is a retelling of the the
Krishna rudder story from the
perspective of Radha herself who in the
kind of classical versions of the story
as you probably know this more or less
disappears and Terry disappears from
from the narrative after Krishna leaves
leaves bridge and did say Krishna Revati
constructs this story in which a trunk
of steel of metal plates inscribed metal
plates are discovered buried in the
tarai and a mysterious sod who turns up
who can read this ancient language and
it turns out to be rad as autobiography
which he reads act to a huge crowd of
people who assemble on the banks of this
river and Easter I and she is she's
feisty she's not taking any any any
nonsense from Krishna she's very
critical of him she has her own path on
her own way and she rejects Krishna
regularly unfortunate as a as a
revolutionary as well not no time here
to go into the detail of that so those
are the most of the five books i've been
i've been thinking about and writing
about and also to try to approach them
in as ads in a more sociological kind of
manner than purely as literature and
think about what their significance and
importance is in this time are this sort
of traditional time in their power as
we've moved from the from the conflict
into perhaps maybe one day some kind of
federal secular republic and there are a
number of features of these novels which
i think are interesting in 1 1 i've just
to identify a few of them one is the way
in which they you some of them three of
them at least have used have used the
past as a position from which to
critique the present Quinn so you
kapatic goes back to the to the imagined
terming mythical past to write a
critique of our ethnic exclusion in a
kind of this magical realist kind of way
that our antic I'll goes back to the
beginning of the Rana regime to write
about the oppressive conventions of of
classical Hindu society under the under
the terms of the Maliki I in the Dalits
of the position of women and so on and
Krista Navarre see again this painters
fable of a liberated Rana rather and the
way in which he forges her in her own
destiny so there's this use of the past
which is not not entirely a new feature
of Nepali literature there's been done
by
for to some extent but these seem to be
much more mobile nuanced too much more
pointed uses of the past and we've seen
seen before there's also the question of
the maoist imprint as i've called it
there's there's there's a considerable
impact on the nepali cultural sphere of
the way in which Maoist ideology has
been propagated through various means
and the literature that at maui's
Car'das and others have produced
particularly in the form of memoirs
which I've published an article about
quite recently and one supposes the
perhaps some of this particularly
perhaps the organ called Korra book the
the the tamang legend it is bearing some
examples some signs of an influence of
Maoist ideology here because it is very
very Maoist and it's in its tone and
content in many ways so one sees sees
this impact I think I'm probably a
little short of time there so I'm going
to wrap up there's also a question of
location and perspective by and large
Nepali literature has been a cup and
eccentric a literature but we see now
increasingly a perspective from outside
the center so a very successful novel
set in the Canal Zone and and also the
tamang perspective so again a
decentering decentralization of it and I
think what's also interesting is one
thing I will be criticized for probably
when I present this in Kathmandu is the
fact that these are all written by
Brahmin men and I make no particular
apology for that because I based it on
on on circulation popularity and so on
rather than in any other criteria
because I'm interested in the impact
they have I was interested to see that
I'd looked at facebook to fight and find
that palpus a cafe had 3123 likes
khiladi blues had 2987 likes
well as organic or quarter prayed kalpa
and rather had only had only a few so
this is quite an interesting reflection
of perhaps the demographic of people who
are reading these particular novels we
have you know an interface between
Facebook and the parley novels which one
could have barely imagined at ten
fifteen years ago but I think what's
significant is that these guys even
though they are Brahmin men are talking
about Jana GRT perspectives are talking
about gendered perspectives and so on
which again is it something one has not
seen in Nepali literature until quite
recently so just to round off this
discussion a significant number of the
people I've discussed these things with
and interviewed in Kathmandu over the
past few years ranging from young Maoist
cardas to public intellectuals are aware
of these novels many have read at least
a few of them and all have opinions
about them so my question really is is
this how important is it for us non
Himalayan scholars those of us who are
non Himalayan scholars who seek to
analyze and comment on political social
cultural issues in this region how
important is it for us to be on the same
page as our interlocutors in the sense
that if vernacular literary and media
production is an important part of the
local discourse what are we what's going
on if if the foreign produced analysis
and commentary doesn't take any account
of it and if our if our answer is that
the reason we can't engage perhaps with
with literature of this nature is
because it requires you know quite a few
years of linguistic training and the
first instance for for somebody from
outsiders society then that raises for
me at least some questions about the
kind of political economy of language
based regionally focused scholarship in
the in the wider sense and i think i'll
i'll leave it there thank you very much
very much
this weekend I've really been privileged
to to be brought behind the curtain as
it were to see those i've i've read or
will read but rarely do i get to witness
anthropologists of the hamaya literary
people with political scientists and
those studying the environment
exchanging views and it's I have more
truck with the Religious Studies
specialists and some more with the
literature but I don't go to two AAA so
it's been inspiring to see you and to
think about some of the issues that I
think show up I hope in commonality with
my own work as a as an art historian and
someone who who does work in the western
regions of the Himalaya which has been
somewhat less as people have commented
somewhat less well represented than the
Nepal Tibet and and perhaps garhwal so I
have been quite literally tried to to
ask myself these the questions that the
organizers asked what do we see when we
look at the hamal what kinds of
strategies and techniques of people in
the Himalaya used over time to represent
themselves their aspirations beliefs
identities etc and as an hour saurian
I've taken that quite literally but I
can only answer this best by translating
it into the the tiny corner of the
himayath that I know best and that's
Jean scar and so I'm hoping that in the
yesterday several times the issue of
scale came up and i'm hoping that in a
way this rather limited constrained look
at a at a particular area will perhaps
provide some analogous avenues worth
exploring
in other regions so certainly not
universally valid principles so just to
remind you Zhang scar of far to the west
actually part of Jammu and Kashmir state
now politically though that has a
historical reference and the my focus is
on the song scar valley which is
relatively small area of this it has
many similarities this constrained
region with other regions of both the
Tibetan or in my opinion to batten eyes
amalia and also long-standing circuits
of exchange with the non Tibetan regions
of the hamaya but it also has you know
naturally distinct characteristics and
historical experience and just to give
you a kind of sense of what the
recognizable culture of course it is
both the economy is based on both
agriculture and animal animal hurting
there's a really strong strong Buddhist
part of the culture at least today Islam
is is quite strong in certain areas but
most of the other villages outside a
couple of towns are in the heart of
Zhang scar our Buddhist there's a lot of
everyday religion ordinary religion both
at lowes are the new years as and these
are these rituals are designed to you
know sort of cast out the obstacles so
they're very much as Todd Lewis was
talking about yesterday focused on
practical practical needs very high
altitude some some of the villages and
so while it might seem isolated you
notice that Loeb song is wearing a UN
hat his son is a member of the ladakhi
Scouts unit a regiment of the Indian
Army that were recently posted in
Lebanon as part of a UN unit so although
we might think of them as isolated
perhaps less so than we think still very
much
involved with a with a hierarchy both in
in the villages and in the monasteries
that is quite important another example
of the of the kind of very practical use
of Buddhist rituals there was a locust
invasion in 2006 and they invited
low-tempo goo from spiti to come really
from delhi to come and perform a ritual
to get rid of the grasshoppers which
there which they succeeded in doing by
having a homo right and one of the
particularity of course that has to do
with contemporary times is the
increasing prominence of nuns in in this
area to certain extent Western supported
but they have been accepted by the
villages and now a lot of of the main
village rituals are actually sponsored
by nuns which is interesting of course
that has a long history of artistic
production which is of course my
interest though in the light of Jeff's
comments yesterday about out-migration
especially of young people and education
that is also often the true now for
artistic production they are either
acquiring things or from dharamsala or
Ladakh these people came in to finish
what artists from dharamsala had begun
and not finished so they brought people
in from Ladakh and so the local artistic
production is actually declining because
of this in a sense out-migration of
cultural resources there there are some
amazing local resources that that
households outside of the monasteries
but householders have texts which were
commissioned by their other ancestors
several hundred years ago
in one case this one in particular it's
dateable because of a reference to a
king in the 17th century and it seems
that these were they're quite different
in content from the of course they
overlap with with productions that were
produced in monasteries but these lay
compilation texts have a great deal of
sort of practical use and one example is
a veterinary text by drukpa Galton that
is aimed at healing diseased animals so
a lot of the the ritual texts in these
compilations are again ordinary religion
and focused on producing immediate
effects so that sort of as an
introduction to the to the range of the
areas that perhaps our art history can
contribute to wider studies I want to
focus now for a few minutes on the kinds
of literally the kinds of strategies and
techniques people have used to represent
themselves and the main way that we can
see people representing themselves is
through depictions of patrons depictions
of donors and they represent themselves
literally over time and what what this
can possibly reveal about relative
origins cultural values gender
differentiations religious history and
other issues of development and finally
I hope I hope to get to the local uses
of photography sankar imagery goes back
of course not counting the petroglyphs
to an early perhaps pre to baton eyes
and and oriented more towards Central
Asia and Kashmir that that some
sometimes these have these are
considered the oldest images
in design scar region and they are I
just point out that that they're in this
triangular niche right right up here and
so the village itself is kind of built
around these early images and there's a
depiction of a donor which you can see
circle and on on the right annealing
donor very small compared to the other
Bodhisattvas and these have some in
terms of the pose the way that they're
dressed can be connected to Kashmir II
based in balti from from Baltistan an
orientation that that in the the pre
Tibetan period they were very much more
involved with with Kashmir and and that
is clear also in some of the some of the
early paintings from a little bit later
than that perhaps where as a tall Chi
they're dressed in a type of clothes and
they're they're acting in a way that it
has much more in common without Persian
eight donors so at least in I'm not
suggesting that these were Persians at
all or or even necessarily Kashmiri but
that the orientation culturally of the
elites was as much towards the west
immediate west as it was towards towards
lalasa at this time though over time we
through looking at the patrons we can
see that that shifts another issue that
comes up is is so-called restoration
so-called development this this kind of
very very pathetic and due solely to I
suppose well-meaning Westerners who
sweep in and decide that that they're
able even on their first trip to Zion
scar they're able to know what is good
for the local people and so they slap
concrete and paint on the these 11th
century objects which within just a few
years are themselves falling apart and
we hope that they won't take the
the whole stupa with them when they do
fall apart also I mean this is just so
discouraging to see that they used a
bucket in order to create the shape of a
finial and then once the scarves
deteriorate they're left with it upside
down buck out on the top of their stupid
it's pretty it's pretty sad but another
issue that needs to be attended to by
the 12th century there's quite a bit of
reorientation towards Tibet rather than
towards Kashmir though the depiction of
the women is somewhat more stable than
and of course there's a there's a big
distinction between goddesses and the
way that the female donors are are
depicted it's not the same they're
obviously an import from Kashmir on the
part of the deities but local clothing
traditions for for the for the donor so
for the sake of time I'm going to I'm
going to skip ahead a little bit another
example of well-meaning restoration but
I want to spend a little time on the
so-called Queen's shorten which is in
car chef one of the larger places of
Jean scar which was added it's beneath a
very old fort and there's a series of
shrines around it it's right across the
defile from the temple ling monastery
and up inside of it are a number of
murals and these murals on one side
depict the first three Dalai Lama's of
course not named as Dalai Lama's but it
gives their actual names plus the first
not even push a so there's a clear
affiliation with with aggie lupa but on
the opposite mural there's a an image of
rachel paw and miller EPPA and in fact
the whole early stem lineage of the of
the
kagu lineage so in the same same small
shrine we have both CAG UN and Gaelic
lineages and it seems that that is
because these were sponsor not by a
monastery not by lineage holders
themselves but by royal families who
supported both simultaneously and
speaking of we can we can sort of dated
because of the images of the donors
which are depicted with some detail at
the bottom left of one of these murals
that show and actually named the gal
pose and the and the queens and we can
sort of triangulate dates through both
the names as well as the styles and you
can see that the donors are sharing a
different kind of culture now that is
closely associated with the Ladakh nam
giao Kings I'll skip the stylistic
issues and just go to there's also long
inscriptions there at the same place
that name all of the people who were
involved and so it's not it's mainly the
elites but it's also the people who
donated beer Chang who worked on it and
so although it's not you know restoring
people to social history exactly it
still elites or at least the conception
of the ELISA there's a little bit more
of air than only the only the names of
the Kings and the the inscriptions also
indicate that the Queen's were heavily
involved with every aspect of it and
that's why I sort of given it the name
Queen's Charton and I'm sort of amused
that that's been picked up locally and
so now they're calling it the Queen's
tartan as well a number of Kings were
depicted in there a number of Queens but
also what may perhaps be one of the
earliest self portraits
the the the artists are are depicted and
named they're like Bashar up there are
also a number of lump owes who are sort
of local head men who are who are named
then indicated there and I want to focus
on that and use that as a segue because
the present date Carson loompa feels
that these are among them must have been
his his ancestors and so I want to turn
now briefly to something that that the
David Zurich addressed yesterday opposed
wonderfully introduced the use of
photography and I think that photography
is an invaluable thing that we should be
attending to and studying because unlike
the internet which tends to it doesn't
leave a record of itself of the rapid
changes photography does there's much
more traces that can be attended to and
so partial loompa has shown me this
photograph that is his the first
photograph of him at first photograph of
his family of that was done in the 60s
not in xong scar he had to travel to to
lay to do it in the in the 1960s and
this depicts his four son he's oh he's a
monk now but this is 10mm yahoo's the
soon to be the he calls himself the new
lump oh now and this is car Shalom poem
on the left these photographs were taken
by they seemed to me to be the first
photographs that people experience now
these are small ID photographs so the
time when people were using them to
identify themselves for government
offices or schools that that's very
interesting and these have been printed
by a Zonk scary photographer who began
working with a photographer in the 60s
inlay and
has still kept these these the negatives
for these but much much earlier
photography this is this is recent but
much much earlier photography was used
at a different register not for ordinary
people but rather for llamas and of
course today photography we're all
familiar with is used by artists in
order to create certain kinds of of very
naturalistic likenesses such as this
image of the 19th couch or bukola who
died in 2003 but using some old
photographs I was able to get into his
clothes shrine that his bedroom
basically at Sankar monastery and there
was a photographic image that was an old
print not a new print of his predecessor
the eighteenth cruise ship baccala who
died i think in 1917 so he owns a number
of photographs and this particular
photograph he he owns a version of it or
it's kept in the monastery but it was
assembled into an album of 1908 so it
had to be photographed before 1908 of
the eighteenth baccala and using
photographs as as professor Zurich
pointed out it's such a prompt if you
bring old photographs people are really
really engaged with them and they open
doors they open people's hearts and by
showing some old photographs I was led
mainly through Carse olimpo to a family
who owns on their shrine when I showed
them these photographs of it oh yeah we
have a photograph of the eighteenth buck
rollin on their families try and they
had their ancestors had given him this
white horse and they had a photograph
taken so I think that the photographs
are really something that we need to
attend to and realize that although they
can be used for exotic exhaust is a shin
kind of Orient oriental ization they
were also circulating
among people and used in in very
different very different purposes that
if we if we create histories of
photography in garhwal at photography in
in Nepal and Ladakh and spiti we can
actually contribute something very much
in the way that Chris Kinney and stir a
slur have done for the larger world
history of photography that's it's it's
very important because they're using
these images in in quite different ways
then people are and understand them to
be used in the West and you know what
this is one example now the twentieth
baccala rinpoche has been recognized and
the this photograph of the child is
installed its treated with attacks with
offered offered reverence and carcel
impo is here introducing himself to the
new incarnation reminding him of their
previous lives interactions and since I
was privileged to go along I I brought
the child photographs of two two
predecessors back and gave them to him
and he snatched them out of out of my
hand and was playing with them and so
will be interesting to to once he grows
up to to find out what his attitude
towards photographs of his own previous
lives might be so I leave it at that
thank you I want to illustrate you start
to my talk with this night map of asia
and you see himalayas and the tibetan
plateau is dark it's so Congress and
some ways this also reflects our sort of
academic work and we invested a look
towards San urologists and we're
studying India and type of the work they
do like Peter produces work you know can
we do say anything like that kind of
work and Tibet then the human eye area
human and adss sortable it's in covered
in dark darkness so this seems them two
ways of illuminating this darkness it's
and one is that the indigenous
communities of a cultural production
literary and dumb visual culture group
productions that may illuminate this
darkness or as we as scholars and
academics some working on the region
through our publications and research
you know we can illuminate this darkness
and some ways when we're looking at them
Tibet and the Himalayas often I don't
know how much of what we write and
publish are really genuine reflection of
what's happening the ground or is it
just based on our own prejudice and our
own performance than that now just take
this example we know great deal about
dip table or ganden monastery table will
say there's a 6,000 months and we know
that at names of the abbot's of the
monastery we know that comes ends we
know their literary productions we know
whose whose teachers great deal about
the scholastic production from there
comes from an ass monastery now imagine
for me to heaven had them six thousand
months and imagine each months require
one kilo of fuel fuel of energy for
keeping warm and cooking and that's
usually done so then it that remains
they require six thousand
kilos of dance every day event that is a
minimum use of energy fuel data so you
in the week that is forty-two thousand
kilograms of done and if you take that
in the month in the month with 1 million
six hundred and sixty thousand kilograms
of done they need so what do we know
about the production of the dance and
how do the accumulator how are they
collected distributed now we have no
idea how do they sustained what is the
material condition that sustains the
Tibetan civilization you know what are
the material based and this was the
question I think Charles and James Scott
was trying to raise last night that we
have no clue about the material
condition under which the Tibetan outer
flourish we can say that long distant
trade salt trade or tea trade but really
we don't have know much about what is d
so that brings to me and don't mind is
is it that because of our own interest
in subtle Buddhism and philosophical
traditions of Buddhism and different
schools is that out researchers be a
focus only on that and not interest in
the material condition or is their
inherent sort of conditions in Tibet
that prevents us from doing any kind of
work on this type say can we write an
economic history of Tibet you know there
is not a single paper on the economy of
17th century Tibet or economy during
tank period we have no idea what are the
conditions of economy on the mill
services on Tibet so this and say some
extent we can say of course is not about
our own prejudice which influence our
research but actually the material
conditions in Tibet you know we don't
have access to archives we don't have
the type of records with people working
on King on Mughal India can get access
to the revenue records now we have
listened it's not available in Tibet and
so it's really hard and so but same time
you know k
can we look at this a look at the set
llamas number in this in a different way
instead of looking at as sort of
spiritual finding of the lineages and
spiritual history or particular sect but
can we do say if you studied number of
Lamos num that in say 14th century can
we find out about land ownership or land
sales of land and in Tibet so in
forgetting about all the religion stuff
just look when the number about land
ownership you know I don't know
importance and dt Barons buy and sell
learned and but sometime in numbers you
have some Lama says he's become and his
report and do you want to go to Tibet
and he had to sell the land to go to
Tibet to to Lhasa and that's what means
to me me my car in 1407 land how did the
sell it what was the land was commodity
and it was economic ahmad and exchanged
and sold so someone is there are
resources way we can look at the back
but it's certain ways we it's our own
prejudice and one example i will give to
my students and talk about this number
of articles and books on the Jewish in
China you know there's so many books and
articles about Dresner totally
disproportionate to the actual number of
Jewish in China or their significance in
Chinese history they don't even deserve
a footnote in Chinese history and there
isn't a man at the peterborough to place
a footnote in his massive book China
March is true there's no footnote about
Jewish in China but there are so many
books on the subject but then we look at
the Tibetan Buddhism penetrate to China
from the tank period to the tunkati
shock kingdom and to the world un mon
tues & Ching you know into deeply deeply
penetrated then and I came to wear of
the extent of the penetration of divine
buddhism in chinese traditional culture
is when i moved to vancouver and you go
to all the Chinese temples in San
Francisco Seattle Vancouver
everywhere on the gate there's a mantra
is written in Tibetan inside the temple
walls all mantras are written in Tibetan
and they have a chat on Jen don't you
know that thousand are my eyes Chandler
sitting there you know one and this is
when you look at the iconography it's
really it's Tibetan sort of paying the
toll I just find it so many where is
that and this is showed me that actually
the Chinese immigrants who came here in
nineteen hundreds they also had to be
linked with the Tibetan Buddhism in this
way so we don't have say or Tibetan
Buddhism in China except a grace book do
duties within nineteenth and early
twentieth century but apart from that we
really don't have a sort of history of
Tibetan Buddhism and it's interchange
with them china so so I think then some
extent it's our own prejudice which
determines them this our own research
now I wonder sis go to now talk about
the literary and visual representation
and the question some antro and since
they have asked me to address and when I
used to travel to Nepal or do Ladakh and
Tibet and I usual as I leave I always
leave about a hundred dollars $150 say
to my friends and say whenever you find
a book new books published can you
please send post me a copy buy a copy
for me and sending and they used to do
it really diligently and I used to get
maybe once every three month one book
but today I cannot afford it to do that
number book is just so many that cannot
ask them to send the books and they
still send me books and I don't even
open them because there's some books on
the philosophy books on the medicine
books on astrology books on science you
know it's just I just collect them and
but then don't even have time to read
because and this is in way reflection
despite the sort of this Tibetan
accusation of Tibetan language in the
verse
destruction or disappearing i would say
in word today that the Tibetan literacy
literary culture Israeli flourishing and
it will be having a renaissance of
Tibetan literature today this rare
moment now one basis of that I'll say is
them in today in never in our history we
had that last number of literate people
today with the literacy rate in Tibet a
man aged 14 to the 30 is almost
seventy-five percent in Tibetan and that
is never an ant type of people who are
literate in the past so months bill
religious figures were literate and very
few layer scribes were illiterate apart
from the compn most common people were
alittle even unchoose were illiterate
because they usually learn by oral
transmission knowledge but today we have
power body of secular ordinary citizens
who are literate and they are and
another sort of way I said that
renaissance is that looking at number of
books published in Tibetan language it
is at sonning and in Tibetan talk to a
circle with this has become sort of
inside joke that Tibet has more right as
than readers you know we produced is the
unique situation will publish so many
books but I don't know who reads them
that button and so today number of books
published is a really fantastic the
publication consists of two literary
world one is reprinting up almost all
tax i would say party library and other
term libraries in Lhasa they more or
less reprinted every sort of books that
were published from 8th century to
present being reproduced and their
bridges made it the sort of in modern
form and they distributed a easily
because in past block print books are
really rare you know it's cannot big
trouble they have to carry on their back
and it's an people kind of go to shops
to buy it and you have the Commission
you have to pay a lot of money
get someone to block print copy for you
so today with the technology is dissing
old books are distributed and people can
possess it own it you know in the past
ordinary families if they had the
different types of get on back you can
get home but another sort of one
textbook that is the sort of most
affordable collection the head and they
were allowed to have a little flag on
their roof but if they had a full set of
conduct danger they were allowed to have
energy in front of their whole house you
know that isn't good house with those
but today they are buying these things
i'm putting in their house almost
everybody said by do this and getting
this morn + it's really cheap and they
can afford it so this also has a
publication of new old books reprinting
has United some of the debates in
philosophy tibetan religion and depends
amulets like that the books which have
not seen red / public since the 14th
century and now suddenly being probably
and then all the buddhist monks are sort
of debate that was left in 1400 and now
being ignited in monasteries in south
india and love wrong and the debating
and who publishing and and if I thought
this is he as the decent gap has never
happened you know and it's a real reason
is that these books have been first time
they're seeing it for themselves in this
way and secondly there's a amount of the
lay people engage in literary production
its enormous everybody's writing their
memoir everybody's writing their village
history you know one of the things that
I get requests from all the events from
Tibet can you find a picture of my
village you know they say Oh am I heard
from my grandfather so some Westerner
went through this village in nineteen
twenty or something and he must have a
photo can you please find this photo for
me that is so unconfident recorded then
looking club and another really now this
stage I would say
it's electronic for production and I say
in for the youth Tibetan Youth as
obviously the iphone safety been
language incredible I haven't really
really saved to divine language and it's
an iphone in Tibet people want them not
because of prestige and the apples good
but ease in which we can drive to battle
and send tibetan text messages so
everyone wants this so the this
technological availability made a sort
everyone to use Tibetan and then and my
son is in Lhasa now and he said
everybody just sort of chatting on their
twitters and everything so it's a really
incredible literacy vibrancy that is
happening and you know it's really
communicating in emails and text
messages this is incredible it's never
happened so in this way I said in both
in terms of use of the language itself
but in terms of production I would say
today now it's really Renaissance of
that a 20 literary and creative culture
is happening of course then this is not
to say then the problem but Tibet also
faces a lot of problem and the first
time in our history we are also faced to
deal with her Germanic language you have
one level in we have to deal with
English and other side we have to deal
with Chinese so there are this great
encouragement of this regiment and when
you talk to them to friends in Lhasa no
Tibetan in class I can say the names of
the days of the weeks in Tibetan they
said Cindy Cindy are they all said day 1
day 2 in Chinese they cannot do and
another thing Tibetans who cannot do
they count in Tibetan that they count
only in Chinese they f they found it and
I found is so frustrating when I'm
informed with them and they have to give
me address or they have to give me a
telephone number and they cannot do it
in Tibetan fussing lost this counting
system that just can go up to 10 and
they say they cannot go beyond it then
and they can only now count in Chinese
and also the method of accounting we
said 10,000 mr. T and boom is hundred
than 100,000 so there's a ten ten
thousand four hundred thousands they
don't say boom they don't even know this
one and do days a week that is so
there's increasing challenge Tibetan
literacy and face in literature faces is
that the encroachment so that right in
terms of our literary production there
are three sort of languages people are
producing you have the devil demand
espera writing in english and the
Tibetans in Tibet writing both in
English and Chinese and that s or
constant debate among the Tibetan is now
what is the vet literature you know do
you define it in terms of ethnicity or
do depend in terms of language use and
2004 when I was in Hazzard doing sort of
meeting with the contemporary writers
and I was leaving I decided I want to
host a party then I invited all the
Tibetans writing in chinese and 12 right
in tibetan and one of the Tibetans
rushing demand said if those Chinese
come we are not coming to your party
they are not present right there there's
a but I said whatever and they don't
write it in Tibetan so they're not to
bend rider if you ever write an article
calling them divine right they said
they're not going to talk to me there's
a and literally I could not hold a joint
party because there was a certain sharp
dislike and it's about food represents
who now this is a big problem and if you
look and say China there's award for
minority literature literary prizes and
it's always given to it demand writing
in chinese so divine language writers i
never get this award or elected to these
prestigious positions in in literary
institutions so it's only those who are
writing in chinese so the tibetan has a
death or in the am though I saw I've
said because all the attention and the
fame is loaded on those who are writing
in chinese of course this is not just a
bad situation you know i mean one of you
writing in Hindi or gujarati no in West
we just think of
the literature we think of some rusty
and all those who great writer to write
in English they don't know about people
writing in indigenous language or do or
Hindi to people that these are
translated so Tibetans also face the
same problem now is that the lack of
exposure and attention from the
hegemonic powers that so where the
Chinese tend to see Tibetan literature
as literature written by Tibetan in
Chinese and them they don't see the sort
of the language you know that Tibetans
are using so this is one of the main
sort of contestation and anchors in
Tibet that's happened and but them
another interesting things that I call
that there has been a great story little
donation because i called you sort of
the collapse of dominance or Buddhism in
a Buddhist hedge enemy is gone in Tibet
now people can write anything they want
subject matter has totally changed you
have novels you have poetry everything
yeah and and one of the way to wait and
people really participating is Tibetan
blockers and writings on internet it
just amazingly vibrant internet forum
that exists in Tibetan language and I
sometime look at these blocks and
understand and then anthropology is
coming back and writing or Tibet this is
totally different report that what the
Tibetans is debating and what
anthropologists taste happening it's
totally different from what they
debating now nobody hasn't written now
but they say and um there's a fight
going on in am though there is a get get
get you it's a ten virtues being
promoted by I forgot the name Lama has
been promoted where they're supposed not
to steal not to be adulterous not to
make a profit not to cheat there's a ten
virtues and every defensible star
adopted this and this monasteries and
the monks are going from household to
household in them don't come say nakid
swear old on observing this give a jew
and there
forcing people so that janky another to
bloggers wrote attack on said this is a
Taliban you know there this is really
and she's a feminist and she just wrote
this attack until you're forcing and did
you abandon people to don't do business
there people shopkeepers have to dare
sell their shops and that's come on but
no and apologies ever reported is the
vibrant debate that's happening there
and this is huge exchange thats happened
similarly in the block say about the
really attacks on llamas and
reincarnation system is vibrant or
debate that is now happening in
blogosphere and sort of visually of
course you all heard of a bama Satan you
know now the Tibetans are winning
international film awards and that's
really interesting and they subject
matter what they tell is really Tibetan
emotional and bama said and some work is
an old dog that was really amazingly
accurate depiction of what's happening
in the in Tibet so just to finish our
some writings that there's a true tropes
in which Tibetans debate the
contemporary things and that one is
rhenium kept to preserving the tradition
or other side it's really nice out there
in a creating new culture so this is the
Tutan and you have the demand espera
they tend to talk about relations are
preserving but it depends in Tibet the
top arenas art but when they mean new
creating new they're concerned with the
very mundane things you know how can we
have dictionary of Technology how can we
turn translate Martin contemporary
terminologies into Tibetan and how
should we translate do we do t cure or
cook your you know what kind of method
we should that's really discount is that
they seized that's a creation not in
some depth with and the others are
talking about why can't we make films
you know what can't we make televisions
from there so there's when they said
weakness at the don't mean they'd what
destroy the whole but they want to what
they called it catching up with the rest
of the society and using like iphone for
tibetan that is arena subject is that
the barbell make unless we make tibetan
language completely integrated with the
martin technology and system our
language will be destroyed when our
language is completely integrated with
the modern technology it will be used
like where iphone has integrated divine
language that made it possible of us to
communicate in tibetan and send text
messages without so I Apple making that
technology available you know we would
have to shift to Chinese or English so I
found safety Tibetan language thank you
a series of talks that have left me on
the one hand fascinated and interested
on the other I feel like I've been
climbing rock climbing and I'm up pretty
high and the Rope has fallen away I
don't know how I'm going to weave
together some comments for you so let me
just start on a personal level is I
think that at least has linked the
interesting talks we heard this morning
um I suffer from the shangri-la syndrome
and I won't pretend that I don't
continue to do that my interest in Tibet
and the Himalayan region began
fundamentally as a teenager the love
affair with the arts and what I could
learn of the Buddha so I'm nonetheless I
went on to a career working in Japanese
Buddhism Buddhist art in particular and
yet I find myself in recent years back
to where I started with an interest in
the iconographic all and stylistic and
ritual practical connections that lead
me from 11th and 12th and 13th century
Japan back to western tibet in that
region more broadly considered so on
this entire way of thinking for me is
posited on what Rogers mentioned a
circuits of exchange of the multiple
connections in a that can occur over a
rather enormous and sometimes unlikely
geographical and chronological expanses
so that's kind of the direction I'd like
to take in a few comments that i have
here as a mindful of our time phones as
well um it seems to me that whether
we're talking about the 10th and 11th
century sir we're talking about today
the sense when we consider circuits of
exchange self-representation seems to be
a really critical aspect of the ways in
which people face-to-face encounter both
cultural difference in cultural
similarities however we might want to
define those terms where the local for
instance meets the global global
interests and local specificities and
it's along to me this is the most
interesting area much of the discussions
that we've heard where the sort of is
the shifting and jostling of connections
that one might not always expected
encounter so this has led me around to
thinking in two ways I kind of have a
macro question and a micro one because I
tend to think in images as an art
historian I was wondering how we I mean
I've heard people talking about the
Somalian region seems to be an entity
there's one way or another connected um
I wondered I'm wondering if the
panelists and others can help me
conceptualize or imagine the model that
we that's being used to talk about this
this space this region a system of
connection
um how do we connect what how do i how
can I imagine it that's a seriously want
to ask this question as it pertains to
my own selfish goal and projects that
I'm involved in right now are we
thinking about this particular listen we
say ho mallet Himalayan region homology
cultures hamayun studies are we talking
about a series of specific areas that
are images of a larger whole and a
fractal sense maybe or is this a system
of integrated like a web address web the
series of student nodes along a great
net that connects everything together
I'm very curious about this issue
because I'm struggling with us I want to
know what does this mean because we from
the talks today and everything I heard
yesterday we're really talking a lot
about a very large number of very local
specificities that are brought together
in this big notion a grant on the grand
scale Himalayan region on a micro level
i'm taking a love science cap we were
rough show that a moment ago um where
i'm wondering in what ways are scholarly
and personal interests in these specific
areas leave a footprint um that should
then be perhaps wrapped into the larger
notion of circus of exchange and the
push and pull along the circuitry where
self-representation i think is is quite
critical what do we have to offer on the
macro and micro levels like I said I'm a
visual person I don't necessarily think
of text so again trying to conceptualize
what this what this is what kind of
place is a million
region and hawaiian studies for any
given locality within it i have a
ingrown resistance to sort of models and
encompass everything into one
singularity so that's fundamentally the
question i have by talking about this
very broad region as if it's one network
or unitarity entity are we ourselves
somehow adding something to the
conversation that might not actually um
necessarily be useful I don't mean to be
rude I'm just wondering about this
question because it's related exactly to
something I'm working on right now and I
cannot I'm obsessed with this issue and
so I asked I think it's come up
repeatedly in the discussions we've had
today already this morning and it will
continue to come up i think i've heard
it yesterday all of us are ultimately
asking something very similar and
personally i need help figuring this out
and there's I think a rather
exhilarating possibility involved in
conceptualizing a model for how you
bring together such incredibly diverse
cultural zones and make them work
together as a group without losing that
specificity so that's my comment for
today in my question thank you
well let's open things up to questions
yes some discussion of that but I just
first want to endorse I think Michaels
and selling call which we have heard
before too during the last couple of
days of enhanced connect dating since we
are talking about him other connections
and has connectivity between two modern
studies and contemporary issues whether
they relate to environment culture
history languages am I to is a very very
appropriate reminder on the last day
second I have a question for Michael and
that is I think I was fascinated by your
intriguing the count on the modern
literature on culture and conflict and
the question is to what extent that can
be isolated form similar literature that
might be appearing in the neighboring
parts of India and then their region in
general because we have many common
animals
apart from religion ethnicity and
political movement and furthermore when
we keep into account what is driving and
accepted accentuating some of these
conflicts and the political economy of
the region staff can answer both
actually quite Simpson just the thoughts
on or maybe very interesting questions
about whether there is an entity called
him early and studies and whether it's
just a we draw a line rather part of the
Earth's surface and defined ourselves in
that I think of it today as there being
a number of kind of overlapping
scholarly communities perhaps and but
maybe one can define them in terms of
that perhaps one way departing them will
be in terms of language so there is a
there is a scholarly community who's
starting point is is stuff ready to
stuff into them and then there's within
that subdivision results subdivisions
within that of people who are using
tibetan for you know the buddhist
textual analysis and then the
anthropologists who are using it as a as
a spoken language for interview and then
the kinds of things that serious talking
about the flogging and so on and then
there's the Nepali focal point and there
are others too but they do interact with
each other I mean for if one if once if
one sort of focal point is like my own
is perhaps primarily Kathmandu there is
also that other world there the Tibetan
sort of sphere overlapping even though
maybe it seems rather marginal
it's been one to the point of view
perhaps in their parties is rather more
marginal but there is a relationship
between them and they do coexist within
a certain space on the question of the
relationship between Nepali Latin
writing and writing in in other South
Asian languages and so on it's a very
close and historic relationship
particularly was writing in hindi but i
would say what's perhaps most
interesting at the moment is the way in
which something i haven't mentioned is
the way in which a number of nepali
writers who are writing in english are
achieving a profile a wider profile so
outside of nepal because this stuff is
written literature written in nepali is
written for a Nepali readership and it's
based on an assumption of the
readerships understanding if one is
writing for a wider readership a lot of
that needs to be sort of sketched in for
an international readership but people
like manjushri toppers summit after
party I and even newcomers like prajwal
Julie that they are beginning to appear
at the Jaipur Literature Festival there
is a relationship developing sort of
internationally between those writers as
well they will tend to deal less with
conflict than people writing in Nepali
itself but yet they're there is some
some some equivalent student I agree and
I enjoyed mimis comments particularly on
two reasons one is this emphasis on the
visual and I think that we see a certain
visual continuity in the culture of the
Himalaya for any number of reasons but
also it it not only shows a very strong
Buddhist and Tibetan influence in many
ways but it shows influence from many
other regions you know we certainly see
the Western influence and we see this
textually also particularly in bonpo
literature but you really do see coming
together of many things the other is
this whole question of what do we share
as students of this world area and using
a geographic term is in some ways as
good as anything partly because many of
us have been
associated with departments or programs
that tried to somehow encapsulate what
it is that actually we all share an
interest in but they call it different
things from high Asia to Central Asia to
interracia to you know the tibeto-burman
world or whatever and it's very
difficult thing to look at I'm curious
as to how the native people view this
and also particularly the question of
nation you know do we have a sense of
local identity and national identity and
it's that rather new or not and I think
that's an area we need to study a lot
more of other telemedicine yes my
operation in the five dollars are there
the top I circulated no votes during the
period more less more or less floorless
so an hour those are written by Neil
wounds not what I found is what mail
bounds here bounds yes one so I was
wondering what was your thoughts on what
would be the reason behind one of the
meal bounds well around six seven
percent of the population doing so well
in the partisan 11 newest feature of
this whole thing is the way in which
journalism and literature have come
closer together so if we look at the
three or four of those five they are all
they've all had prior to publishing
their novels a profile nationally as the
columnist or a journalist new particle
rights political pieces and then I went
right now obviously was the editor of
can't equal and so on so i think that
the kind of the the way in which male
bones get to the top of the pile in
areas like journalism has translated
itself into literature sphere as well
but I mean it always it always has been
male bones and mail mail
after their wives that have dominated
Nepal in writing I mean there is there
is a as you know there is also an
increasing production of writings in
Nepali by by people from our diversity
geology RT backgrounds I mean the this
new novel by rajan mu garden and then
poetry by shrub on mccadden i think is
it our general carbon and so on
regarding that I mean these are these
are I'm currently reading those actually
but I haven't including them in this one
because they seem dr. have the same
level of circulation or at least they
haven't had up until now they're fairly
new but we are we are the point I was
making was that even though these are
written by bow in males they still are
incorporating a lot of different
perspectives so you can see that they're
writing in an environment where perhaps
as a sense that the old kind of Katmandu
centric assumptions of nepali society
can no longer be replicated in the
writings even of our males was the point
I was kind of trying to make but that
isn't to say that there aren't you on a
GRT writers are beginning to emerge as
well more in poetry I think at the
moment that in the novels as such so are
picking up on our needed idea of
circulation ideas i wonder what the
authors that that mike is discussed
would have to say in conversation with
the writers that tearing has discussed
and by that I mean to what extent are
they facing similar issues are they
writing about similar ideas are they
right against similar kinds of ideas
plus it just some the sort of connection
in Himalaya sort of quite interesting
and this picture of meeting the
interaction Britain people from nepali
areas to Tibetan areas and today most of
people are sort of bilingual they speak
Tibetan Nepali most of my niece and
nephews and everyone you know they're
bilingual totally did that and another
user of the centuries of Nepal team and
we don't even have any palliative
dictionary you know and that there's
finish the baton dictionary I don't know
how many people require haha it is not
an A+ and in dictionary yeah and no one
has to produce one is this because
there's no need for one or the reflects
the level of interaction there is no
sort of literally interaction or
intellectual interactions it's almost
over trade or commerce that links the
people of him unless and not the sort of
the intellectual discussion that is
happening so of course the subject
matters at the yesterday when people are
talking I thought I'm really the him
truly human lying person because if i
look at my sort of answer is my kinship
and my family I mean we are Tibetan we
are never a web girl room we are from
seeking work from Bhutan and relatives
everywhere and they all we are so prima
CEOs we don't have hesitation of
marrying anybody you know entered my
relatives are married to gurus that
married to commons that the American
lectures as it it's mingling of that
then the entire sort of human line belt
I have relative so I think in some sense
really will become sort of truly hemline
family and that way but that is in terms
of subject matter is very different
because the two influences is that red
different that they deal with them I
don't know whether Napa they've nepali
two writers of dead feeling that they're
writing on the verge of an tech tech
culture is under attack there and the
threatened the Tibetan so almost all our
routing with this sense that their
culture is under attack and that the
thread their identities and virg to
disappear so that is constant when you
ask any demand rather why do you like
they say for safety bed in language you
know that they're writing that's you
don't have no it's not the case with no
and I think but these are very different
social and political spheres as well I
don't think there's a great deal of
consumption by by one by the other at
least if we're talking about the kind of
tibetan plateau as a geographical area i
don't
I don't imagine there's a great
circulation of writings of Nepali there
and vice versa oh yeah i mean only is
that they own they translated your mahna
mahna mahna mutton 4mon imagine they've
got it's written nepali untranslated
English through English it was
translated it Tibetan that reason it was
translated into Tibetan once some
Nepalese Prime Minister was with in
Tibet and the Chinese Court did they
have to present something to him and
they've got my friend said Academy
social science to translated and they
wrote ask me said they we have to
translate the Nepali include Wentworth
mechanic find it has allowed in now mark
Rhodes translation so it's not mono
Martin wasn't even because they thought
it was most important nepali literature
it was the only thing i knew developing
i was very fortunate to meet the the
translator of him in a modern into
chinese also in new york and it turned
out he'd also used my english
translation and with a Mullen rather
than the original nepali so you wonder
what what was being lost to seek as
emotional end you know yes okay if you
look at television news footage into bad
weather than Howie leader visits to them
and they have those very very
orchestrated futuristic meetings on
television sitting either side of a
flower pot with the picture of the
Potala I you find that we will only ever
see with a Nepali official visiting a
Chinese official that there's only one
interpreter and he's sitting behind the
Chinese because the Nepalis don't bring
it to Bement up to win so they entirely
rely upon which is a way of signaling
very low level of resources which is
quite quite serious issue so they have
to allow the Chinese translator
two questions one is to Michael about
the the makings of a lot to someone from
sams concerns the the economics of
publishing novels self-published stupid
you know that also puzzled rüsselsheim
who's publishing and the other the other
one is to do Rob I really appreciate
looking at the donors and all of these
hand again is this interesting way of
reading against the usual interpretation
for living engine and iconographic and
things like that to look at the clothing
and the situation that led do you think
you have any reason to think that the
portrayal of donors is more badla
stiffening no is more realistic in other
words can we really read social history
out of the portrayal of those donors
so I think young children well of course
there is a certain amount of projected
the donors are going to be portrayed in
the way that they wish to create as they
as I hope to be rather than necessarily
as as they are but I do think that they
play roles that the role is as much
being portrayed as that individual
person and in that way the social role
is I just want to especially differences
were there perhaps more references to
Persian to ship them and urgently
created styles that might actually have
been found in the wood there cept is it
possible that their self representation
would have partly come out of a real of
different politically
I think they really create that that's
very true that in terms of the material
culture of kingship the kinds of
textiles that would require version 8
and the other images of kingship weirdos
of his audience it seemed circulated so
whether aspirational I hope we'll all
notice the portrait of Henry Luce in the
gathering area outside you in doubt the
building but on the economics of
publishing it's very interesting the way
it's changed and it's a much more
commercial operation sorry Tyrone it
much more commercial operation than it
was 20 years ago so until until the 90s
I guess the main publisher was Sergeant
percussion which was basically a
government subsidiary and but only one
of those novels was published by sajan
air and these are small private
publishers by and large and they they
are making profits this is a commercial
operation is marketed and sales are much
much larger than anything that went
before like like like the Tibetan sphere
I suppose you know we've got you know
much if you look at literacy in Nepal a
number of literate people has doubled
every 10 years in the last 30 years or
so so the market is there that wasn't
there perhaps even 10 years ago is only
actually before I asked the question is
commenting on the Persian style
might have been one of the truth there's
a reference to 10 ultimate Emperor a
real question meeting the Chinese
delegates I think very fine description
of them wearing silk brocade and a silk
turban the color of dawn is very
careless was wearing a natural question
arose Trotsky was about the veterinarian
manual horse lottery is there just one
that you know I found it on TV RC so
that exists other than was picking our
main street but it's the only
illustrative furniture which is racing
the ex-king is about posts fostex right
and how you tell from the teeth I've
already seen a discussion of this is
serious I didn't plan to any discussion
on horses i'm always accused of probably
too much enthusiasm for the british art
center because i actually like the stubs
horses there but that I think we wraps
it up for now and will be a journey for
sure